[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute mache ich eine richtig leckere
mousse au chocolat also eine schokoladen
mousse oft zeugt ja und für die mousse
au chocolat verwendet er wirklich nur
ganz ganz wenige zutaten wichtig dabei
ist im prinzip einfach nur die
schokolade
ich hab jetzt hier eine tat bitter
schokolade eigentlich eine edel
bitterschokolade mit über 60 prozent
kakaoanteil und die schokolade hat uns
unser freund eberhard geschenkt
überhaupt stellen der hat nämlich in
heilbronn hat eine schokoladenmanufaktur
und die habe ich auch bei meiner einfach
sally sendung besucht und dort habe ich
die schokolade mitgenommen und macht
damit jetzt die mousse au chocolat und
dadurch wird die mousse au chocolat
natürlich noch einen tick leckerer falls
sie jetzt nicht unbedingt eine
schokoladenmanufaktur oder einem
chocolatier um die ergab so wie wir
könnt ihr natürlich einfach eine herren
schokolade nehmen die hat nämlich über
60 prozent kakaoanteil
ich denke ich mal die übrigen zutaten
für die mousse au chocolat verwende ich
200 gramm peter schokolade 50 gramm
sahne einen espresso
der ist noch heiß 4 eigelb vom eiweiß
eine prise salz 50 gramm zucker und 200
milliliter sahne
ich gebe jetzt zuerst die sahne in den
topf also die 50 gramm sahne ich weg die
übrigens immer in gramm ab nicht im
milliliter weil ich mir so einfach denn
messbecher sparen ich kann so einfach
das glas auf die waage stellen und bei
sahne entspricht 200 gramm auch 200
milliliter das passt hier gebe ich den
espresso noch dazu die fliege bleibt
bitte weg ich weiß nicht warum wir
fliegen gibt trotzdem fliegen egal
jetzt lasse ich kurz die sahne mit dem
espresso aufkochen und kann ja auch
schon mal die schokolade einfach so eine
feine stücke teilen
dies ist super lecker der ebrd hat mir
übrigens gezeigt wie man schokolade
richtig ist und zwar so dann nehmt ihr
euch ein kleines stück und dann müsste
auch wie so ein hase ablagen also
und daumen im mund schmelzen lassen
nicht kauen die nächsten fünf minuten
mache ich jetzt eine stumpfe gerät nicht
mehr den herd habe ich ausgemacht jetzt
kommt die schokolade hier ein schwenk
den top so ein bisschen damit die
schokolade auch wirklich komplett mit
der saale und dem espresso überzogen ist
und falls ihr keine nespresso mögt
könnten einfach weglassen und
stattdessen noch mal ein bisschen mehr
samen nehmen aber der ist presse gibt
noch mal ein richtig tollen leckeren
geschmack dazu gibt's einfach ein
bisschen rühren bis die schokolade
geschmolzen ist
das zweite was ganz wichtig ist bei der
mooser schokolade sind die eier die
sollten nämlich ganz frisch sein und war
bevor ich sie trenne wasche ich sie auch
immer gerne ab und so kann ich einfach
sichergehen dass später wirklich keine
salmonellen drin landen wobei die reihe
wirklich sehr frisch sind also ich gebe
jetzt zuerst einmal das eiweiß in der
schüssel
da kommen die prise salz dazu und ich
kann sie kurz steif schlagen
[Musik]
sobald der schnee dann steif ist kommt
der zucker langsam dazu und der
verhindert dass der schnee später flog
auch unser leben aber noch mal kurz
führen damit die masse wirklich
entscheiden jetzt ist der schnee schon
steigt
ich warte immer nur auf den moment an
dem der schnee dann doch runter rutscht
nämlich eine zweite schlüssel da kommt
jetzt die geschmolzene schokolade rein
[Musik]
dann noch die eigelbe
kann ich die masse auch cremig verrühren
und dann noch die sahne steif schlagen
die muss ich jetzt schnell arbeiten
damit einfach die schokolade jetzt nicht
schon fest wird das heißt jetzt im
nächsten moment direkt die sahne noch
steif schlagen
jetzt kann ich hier einfach alles
unterheben
also erst einmal den eischnee in die
schoko masse der macht das ganze
natürlich super locker und luftig es
gibt auch rezepte komplett ohne sahne
also wirklich nur mit eiern und
schokolade
aber ich finde mit sahne noch einen
ticken besser aber ich glaube da musst
du chocolat es halt auch so da hat jeder
so sein eigenes rezept und ja muss man
schauen was einem am besten schmeckt das
vorsichtig unterheben und ihr könnt hier
natürlich auch gewürze dazugeben so dass
das ganze weihnachtlich wird zum
beispiel sind passt ganz gut
chilli passt ganz gut lebkuchengewürz
können dazu geben
aber ich mache es heute eine ganz ganz
klassische dann die sahne unterheben und
dann sind wir auch schon fertig
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr die museen eine große
schüssel füllen und abdecken und dann
praktisch raus löffeln diese kleinen
lockten die man kennt oder ihr fühlt sie
in kleine dessert gläser das finde ich
immer ein bisschen schöner dann nehme
ich zum einfüllen immer ganz gerne einen
spritzbeutel so kann ich nämlich richtig
sauber arbeiten braucht man auch keine
gülle
ihr könnt auch ein gefrierbeutel zum
beispiel nehmen
dort oben verschließe ich den schritt
immer gern mit einem gummiband so fließt
einfach nichts raus damit zogen die
spitze wegschneiden
[Musik]
jetzt war schließlich die diese gläser
und dann kommt die mousse au chocolat
für etwa vier stunden in den kühlschrank
wichtig ist dabei im prinzip nur dass
sie am gleichen tag oder spätestens am
nächsten tag verzehrt wird weil eben
[Musik]
die mousse au chocolat ist jetzt fertig
sie sitzt fest geworden und murat sezer
geht auf das probieren ich seit glaube
ich die schokoladen experten ja man
sieht auch stell dich mal links und sehr
mag neben mich ja dem mikrofon werden
wir zwei moscheen schritt wie sie die
blöd aus immer meins kleiner tipp
probieren
ich hab die schokolade von eberhard
benutzt übrigens kommt am sonntag die
sendung war einfach sally und zwar bin
ich dabei hat in der
schokoladenmanufaktur und ich mache
richtig richtig tolle torte also ganz
außergewöhnlich oldschool ist wenn musik
ob man jemals zu süß dann ist schon ein
paar löffel lag schumacher ich kann
nicht mehr
und das ist richtig schön bisschen sagte
becker ich habe auch ganz wenig sogar
also nur wirklich noch 50 gramm und
wichtig ist dass man eben eine ganz
dunkle schokolade nimmt also bei der
schokolade ich nehme halt immer zart
bitter oder edelbitter weise auch wenig
zu spät dass kenia und dann schmeckt
halt schokoladen und genau
vollmilchschokolade
warum also macht echt nicht den fehler
und nehmt vollmilchschokolade schon gar
nicht
ja damals auch mit weiße schokolade
macht ja weiße schokolade schon dinge
manche sagen weiße schokolade wer keine
schokolade weil sie keinen kakao enthält
das habe ich übrigens ein eber hat auch
gefragt aber es ist ja trotzdem
kakaobutter und alles drin
ja kann ich machen aber es wird halt süß
es wird extrem sind dunkle augenbrauen
nichts dazu
ich hab lange jetzt überlegt mache ich
noch eine soße oder irgendwie man aber
man braucht einfach nichts dazu super
und wisst ihr was ich habe nicht mal
länger als zehn minuten gebraucht nur
die kühe zeit ist das einzige können
morgens euch hinstellen kurz die
mutterrolle auch in richtig großer menge
zu bereiten in den kühlschrank stellen
und am abend seien wären eigentlich toll
auch ein tolles weihnachtsfest was ich
gut wie möglich mit physalis zusammen
das lego ja nicht mehr wirklich genial
und super zum nachmachen empfohlen
ihr habt jetzt hier innerhalb von vier
minuten ich habe noch ein paar keine
sorge
sobald ihr das rezept nach machen wollt
schaut auf 6 - blog.de vorbei und fragt
ihr noch mehr schoko infos haben möchtet
und wissen wollt was für eine richtig
coole torte ich am sonntag mache dann
schaltet unbedingt ein um 16 uhr auf vox
genau der ewer hat der freut sich die
wahl ich grüße nicht ganz lieb überhaupt
schön ich mache auch mal für dich eine
musische dollar ok mit deiner schokolade
[Musik]
ich habe die vision eine
schokoladentorte herzustellen wie sie so
noch keiner gegessen hat sally zaubert
ein meisterwerk genuss hektar für
kalorienbewusste essig und schokolade
habe ich noch nie verknüpft wird sich
standen nur süß das wird eine richtige
geschmacksexplosion glückshormone
garantiert schokolade ohne reue
sonntag 16 uhr bei vox